foreign
[Music]
just a rod made up of atoms can
electricity flow through it if it's just
kept as is that possible
not really because what electricity
needs is a complete Loop or a circuit
this is a battery and this is a wire
from which the electricity will flow
as you can see the path is completed
from one end to the other
with this Loop there will be a constant
flow of electrons
notice that in this figure electricity
is being generated but not being used
for anything at all it's just getting
wasted
let's put it to good use by using it to
light up a bulb
this is the battery this is a switch
this is a wire and this is a light bulb
when the switch is closed the circuit is
complete and when it's open the circuit
is not complete
and without the circuit we will not have
electricity which will light up this
bulb
when the switch is closed the electrons
start flowing and the bulb is lit up
you can try opening and closing the
switch to understand when the bulb
lights up and when it doesn't
what about the material of this wire
will electricity flow irrespective of
the material of The Wire
no it will depend on the material
some materials allow electrons to flow
more easily or freely among their atoms
while some do not
when do you think electrons will move
easily between atoms
that's right when they're not too
tightly bound to their own atoms
such Elements which have very mobile
electrons are called conductors
so when we want to make electric wires
we use good conductors of electricity as
they assist in electron flow
metals like copper silver and gold are a
few of the best conductors of
electricity
what about elements with low or low
conductivity
they are called insulators they prevent
the flow of electrons rubber and plastic
are good examples of insulators
okay so coming back to the main point of
electric current
how would we Define it it is simply the
rate of flow of electric charge
which means it is the amount of charge
flowing through a particular area in
unit time
more the charge flowing in unit time
more will be the electricity
one last point about electricity
in an electric circuit the direction of
electricity is taken as opposite to the
direction of flow of electrons
if the electrons are flowing in this
direction then the direction of flow of
electricity will be in the other
direction
[Music]